>> Peter Vankevich: OK.
This is the last very wonderful
day here at the Kitchen Stage.
And I do want to once again
thank our ASL interpreters
who have done a wonderful job
since 10 o'clock this morning.
Stand up, stand up.
[Applause] It is a very
important duty here.
So, all right, I have
Ms. Eun Yang from NBC,
big anchor for our
local TV here.
Welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Eun Yang: Thank
you so much, Peter.
Good evening, everyone.
What a crowd, look
at all these people.
It's awesome to see so
many people in attendance
of the National Book Festival.
I was an avid reader.
Now, I'm a "try to steal time
whenever I can while I'm driving
my children around" reader.
And I love this event so much.
It's my eighth year at the
National Book Festival.
I look forward to coming every
year because authors are treated
like rockstars as they should
be and I get to meet some
of my favorite authors
including the one I'm
about to introduce tonight.
Thank you so much to the
Library of Congress for hosting
such a fantastic event.
This conversation is sponsored
by the James Madison Council.
So even before Reese Witherspoon
fought for the rights to adapt
"Little Fires Everywhere" for TV
and brought in Kerry Washington
to co-star in the show
even before it was a summer
of Asians, the August of Asians,
Celeste Ng set our
consciousness ablaze
with her powerful stories.
I think we've run
out of accolades
to describe her writing.
After reading her books, I'm
left with so many questions
about her characters but more
about myself and my life.
And I think that's why
her books are so amazing.
And today, she'd sit down with
fellow talented writer Rumaan
Alam, the author of "Rich
and Pretty" and "That Kind
of Mother", who's also an editor
of the New York Times books,
so two big deals up here on
stage, ladies and gentlemen.
I'm very much looking
forward to this conversation,
Celeste Ng and Rumaan Alam.
[ Applause ]
>> Rumaan Alam: Hearing our
credentials laid out like
that makes me feel really
happy for our Asian mothers.
I feel like the Asian mother out
there is like, yes, you know?
>> Celeste Ng: Do they know how
to do that because there's--
>> Rumaan Alam: That's fair.
>> Celeste Ng: I sent
my mom, at one point,
a picture of the New York Times
best-seller list with me on it
and her reply letter was,
great, going down to brunch
in a few minutes, love you.
And that was what it was.
And I feel like--
>> Rumaan Alam: I just-- I was
in California not that long ago
and I met a friend's aunt
who is an Asian mother.
And my friend introduced me, she
said, oh, this is my old friend,
Rumaan, he wrote two books.
And she was like, mm-hmm.
And she said, oh, he is also an
editor at the New York Times.
And she said, oh,
the New York Times.
[Laughter] I'm supposed
to warn the audience
that when we ask questions,
you're going to be on camera,
you're going to be recorded.
So, if you are in the federal
witness protection program,
please do not come
up to the microphone.
Celeste and I will-- Celeste
will take some questions,
we'll give you a heads-up a
few minutes before the end
of the program.
I'm not going to bother
introducing Celeste
because I would love to
see by a show of hands
who in this room has read
one or both of her books?
Yeah, OK. So, a few weeks ago,
Penguin Random House tweeted
that you had a million copies
of your new book in print--
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah, I don't
want to impugn them but I feel
like that has to
be a math error.
>> Rumaan Alam: I don't
know, I don't know.
I-- You think it's fake news
but you just saw
everybody raise their hand.
So I'm not going to waste
our time talking too much--
in too much detail about,
you know, the plot specifics
or the mechanics
behind these two books.
But you are-- your
book came out when,
earlier this spring--
this fall, right?
>> Celeste Ng: No,
it came out at fall,
came out September of 2017.
>> Rumaan Alam: Wow, really?
Gosh, I haven't seen
you in a long time.
So, from the distance of,
you know, quite a while now,
how does it-- how does your
relationship to the book
that you have spent the past
few months touring about change?
And then how does your
relationship to your first book,
how has that changed
over that time?
>> Celeste Ng: I think the best
analogy that I have for sort
of the relationship that I
have with both of my books is,
it's a little bit like a
parent who has got a child
and the child has grown up and
is theoretically going away
to college and then comes back
and moves back into your house
and keeps asking you
to do their laundry,
do more of their things,
and you're like, please,
like I just-- I need
to just move on.
And I'm really-- I still
love my books but I also feel
like I need to let them
live their own lives,
if that makes any sense.
But I'm really happy to keep
getting to talk about the books
because the characters
are still very real to me.
And I still think about them
periodically and so it's sort
of nice that they're
still calling in a way.
>> Rumaan Alam: It's
a complicated balance,
I would imagine, to be a writer
of a book that is so successful
because you were
sort of liberated
by the success of the book.
But then as you said, you're
still doing the book's laundry.
So how do you make the time--
how do you make the time now
as an artist to keep writing
and to keep thinking and to have
that sort of sustained
quiet focus that you need
to do the work of a novelist?
>> Celeste Ng: That's been a
real sort of learning process
for me, is figuring out
how do you, you know,
turn down the volume on the
things that you need to do
that you want to do to
support the work you've done
and to keep making new stuff?
And one way that I
did in honesty is
that I set myself
really unrealistic goals
and then I tell my friends these
goals and I tell my agent--
our agent these goals as a
sort of way to be accountable.
So I'll say, OK, by
the end of this summer,
I'm going to have a
draft of a new book.
And they'll look at me
and go, OK, good, do that.
And I don't usually actually
hit those goals but it's a ways
of sort of reminding myself
that these are the things
that I still have to do.
>> Rumaan Alam: Because
I guess the question is,
what is your job as a writer?
Is your job to be a
public person and to tweet?
I think you like to use Twitter.
>> Celeste Ng: Most
of the time, yes.
>> Rumaan Alam: Or is your
job to sit down in isolation
and quiet and have your
sort of family life
and your quiet working
focused life?
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah,
and this is a question
that I've been asking myself,
especially over the
past few months.
I feel like my job first is to
write my books, but I realized
that these other things are
part of my job too, like to come
and do public events like
this, to go to schools and talk
to students, sometimes to write
essays or to talk on Twitter.
And where the line is, is going
to be different for everybody.
But it's a thing that I'm
sort of feeling out what feels
like work that I want to do.
So I keep answering it by
coming down to what am I trying
to accomplish with
any of the work?
For me, it tends to be, I want
to be an advocate for empathy.
I want to be an advocate for
people, imagining what it's
like to be other people,
and for holding open space
for contradiction
and for grace basis.
And so then anything that I
can do that fits in that space,
I think of as being my work.
>> Rumaan Alam: A
worthy use of your time.
>> Celeste Ng: We said we
were going to be light.
>> Rumaan Alam: Oh
I'm sorry, you guys.
We should talk about
something fun.
OK, we'll lighten up.
So, you're two books
into a career,
you're still a very young woman.
Are you conscious of
having a territory
as a writer that is yours?
Can you see a pattern
between the two books?
Or are you still
too close to them
to even define those patterns?
>> Celeste Ng: I
think I'm too close
to them to figure that out.
I think other people are doing
a better job frankly of sort
of seeing the connections
between my--
>> Rumaan Alam: All
right, do you want me
to just tell you what they are,
because I wrote them
down for you?
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah, I
was like-- You're fishing.
>> Rumaan Alam: Do you want me
to mansplain them
to you, Celeste?
I'm happy to.
>> Celeste Ng: Rumaan,
please tell me
about what my work is about.
>> Rumaan Alam: Well, I was
thinking about place with both
of your books which is
a significant factor
in both of the books.
And I just said I wasn't
going to do too much summary
but Celeste's first
book is called
"Everything I Never Told You".
It is the story of the sort
of questions around the death
of an adolescent in
a biracial family
in what I would maybe call
like ex-urban Ohio,
more than suburban--
>> Celeste Ng: Yes,
a small town.
>> Rumaan Alam: Like a
small town, a college town--
>> Celeste Ng: I think I said it
was halfway in between Cleveland
and Toledo, because there's
not a lot between there.
>> Rumaan Alam: I
went to Oberlin
so I was picturing
Oberlin the whole time.
>> Celeste Ng: A lot
of people have asked me
if it's sort of based
on Oberlin.
And it's not based on Oberlin
specifically but that sort
of thing, where it's a sort
of self-contained
little college town.
It's not on the-- It's not
attached to a city of its own.
It's a sort of--
>> Rumaan Alam: Right.
But it feels very much of Ohio.
And Celeste's new book, "Little
Fires Everywhere" is much more
difficult so summarize but it is
the story of a suburban family
and their entanglement with
another suburban family
in Shaker Heights,
Ohio, which is sort
of the prototypical
American suburb.
And so, I was thinking about
the suburbs and I was thinking
about Ohio and wondering
if you feel like, you know,
that's where you're from.
But is that your subject
or are you surprised
that someone might say
that it is your subject?
>> Celeste Ng: I'm
not surprised.
I think that's accurate so
far based on these two books.
I think I keep finding myself
returning to the suburbs
because we kind of look at our
own past a lot of the times
to sort of figure out how we
became the people we became.
And I'm very much a
product of the suburbs.
You know, my parents wanted
a lawn and good schools
and a grocery store
that had a parking lot.
I live in Boston where grocery
stores don't always have parking
lots, which just
boggles my mind.
But you come from New
York, so yeah, same.
But so, there's something
about this suburban world
that really fascinates me.
And I feel like part of it is
that the suburbs are maybe
quintessentially the place
where you're trying
to have it all.
You're trying to have the
best parts of the urban world
and the best parts of not
being in the city, right?
You get to have all the culture
and you're close to the city
but you don't have to
deal with the crowds
and the traffic, right?
You get to have the lawns
and a little space around you
but you still have neighbors
and community where it's harder
to have out in the world.
And I would find myself coming
back to this idea about trying
to have it all because that--
the flip side of that is
what did you miss out on?
What are you not getting?
And that's sort of one of
the themes that I think runs
through both of the
books, is sort of--
what are your questions about
the life that you missed out on
and the choices you didn't take,
the path that you didn't follow?
Those are the questions that I
ask myself a lot, and that seems
to be what comes up a lot.
>> Rumaan Alam: By rigorously
focusing on the suburbs,
you kind of exposed
the larger world,
the world just beyond the
physical borders of this place
that is seemingly ordinary
and orderly, right?
>> Celeste Ng: I
think that's it.
I mean, I think we have
an idea in our minds
about what the suburbs
look like,
what they're supposed
to look like.
We have an idea about the
people who might live there.
And by trying to zoom in
on that a little bit more,
I want to sort of expose
what that says about us
as a wider society, what
are we striving for,
because I think the suburbs are
sort of seen often as this place
of striving, that you are
striving to better yourself.
You're striving for position.
You're striving for all these
things, what that says about us
and sort of our values
and where it is
that we think we're
supposed to be.
>> Rumaan Alam: I think when
we use the word suburb now,
it can sound kind of
demeaned or smaller.
But I think about sort
of the great golden age
of television narratives
like "Leave It to Beaver",
in which the suburb was sort
of like the paramount
American existence.
And the suburb as a
territory for a writer
of fiction has been
rich material
for writers like John Cheever.
Like it is a serious subject
and a serious territory
that maybe we don't hear that--
the term itself doesn't have
that connotation any longer.
And one of the things
that I most
like about the Celeste Ng
suburb is you very cannily
and subtly talk about race
and other kinds of difference.
And it's always a tricky thing
with a writer who is a person
of color to say like, talk to me
about being a person of color,
and talk to me where
that is in your work,
because that's reductive,
and your work is
about a lot more than that.
Having said that, I want
you tell me about it anyway.
>> Celeste Ng: That's
also-- It is a part of that.
I mean, the work is about race,
and that is part
of what it's about.
Earlier, I was sitting
in the back
when Andrew Sean Greer
was talking, and he talked
about how he was at school and
he will come up and say like,
so I never met a
gay person before.
What's that like?
You know, and it's sort
of a funny question
but it's also underneath that is
an honest desire to learn more
about someone who's maybe had a
different experience than you,
and I think that's admirable.
There's a moment in
"Everything I Never Told You",
in my first novel, in which one
character asked another like,
you know, so, you
know, you're the only--
you know, you're the only person
who's like you in this community
that are one of the few Asians.
And he says, what's that like?
And she doesn't really now
how to answer that exactly.
So, I mean, my experience
of it has been it's a lot
like what I believe the
experience of not being a writer
of color is like, plus a
whole bunch of other things
that we get to think about that
a lot of other people don't.
And I think that's where
we start talking about sort
of like questions of privilege.
What are the things that
you never have to worry
about because they're
not a part of your world
where they're a part of mine?
We talked about Twitter.
And one of the things that,
you know, Twitter is known for,
I think, is being a-- I'm a
looking for a polite word.
>> Rumaan Alam: A cesspool?
Is that a polite word?
>> Celeste Ng: I should say
a space of contention maybe,
that is the place to put it--
>> Rumaan Alam: What
a diplomat, Celeste.
>> Celeste Ng: It's a place
where I think that, you know,
because people can
be sort of anonymous
and you're disconnected from
people, people can say a lot
of things that they
wouldn't otherwise say.
And it's been an interesting
experience to be a woman writer,
and then a woman
writer of color,
and then who's now gotten
something of a large profile
to just sort of see what kinds
of assumptions people make
about me, you know, and what it
is that they think I'm saying,
and what it is they think
I'm supposed to be doing.
This-- I think about these
sorts of things a lot honestly
because there's--
we have this idea
that there can only be one
writer of any particular kind.
And so, there's this-- I wrote
an essay a long time ago called
"Why I Don't Want to Be the
Next Amy Tan", which I meant not
at all as a disrespect to Amy
Tan, but that I wanted to push
against this idea that we could
only have one Chinese-American
woman writer--
>> Rumaan Alam: At a time.
>> Celeste Ng: -- at a time.
And so, if someone else was
going to come in and want
to be a Chinese-American woman
writer, they were going to have
to basically like knock
Amy Tan off her pedestal.
And I would like her just
to stay and keep writing.
And I think this is one of the
things, I think, that writers
of color face a lot, is that
this question of representation.
>> Rumaan Alam: But what's so
startling about that is that,
particularly with "Little Fires
Everywhere", although it--
of course it talks about race
and those of you in the room
who have read it will understand
the ways in which it engages
in that conversation,
in summary,
when you describe what the
book is about, it is a book
about a wealthy white
family with four children
in the suburbs of
Cleveland, Ohio.
So, you are not a white person
but you have written
on this subject.
Obviously, you know
what you're doing.
Obviously, you're doing
that with some intention.
Can you explore--
Can you explain
to me what that intention is?
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah.
I think I was asked in
an interview recently
like why write about people
of color in relation to sort
of the larger white community,
which I think is a
really valid question,
and one I haven't been
asked in that form before.
And my answer was
something like, well,
there's definitely a value, I
think, to writing about sort
of your own community.
You know, a marginalized
community for me,
it would be Chinese-Americans or
women or Chinese-American women,
because there's a value
in telling those stories.
But the thing is that we
don't exist in a vacuum.
And, you know, I have
always grown up in places
where I'm in the minority.
And I think there's a value in
sort of holding those things
up together and saying,
this is the context
in which this experience
is happening.
I think if you are a writer of
color for example and you write
about just this one
community in isolation, first,
I'm trying to imagine
how that would happen.
I'm trying to imagine how
you would write a story
about any family of color
and not include any other--
you know, any other, you know,
any part of the larger
sort of white community.
But second, I think
there's always--
there's a danger than can happen
where people go to those sorts
of books as sort of
like a literary tourism,
where they're like, I'm going
to read this and I'm going
to learn a lot about
this community.
And then I'm going to close the
book and it will be like that's
when I get on the plane and
I go back to my own life.
And I think there's a value in
being asked to sort of think
about how these communities
engage with each other.
And so one of the things that I
wanted to write about in writing
about my hometown, Shaker
Heights, was how the families
that live in this area look at
people who are from outside.
And then this is something
that you have dealt
with in your own writing too,
because in both of your novels,
you also write people who
are not-- you know, there's--
it's not a Rumaan like stand-in,
there's no direct
you in the book.
>> Rumaan Alam: Yeah.
In some ways, I think
that the very convention
of a literary novel is kind of
a white place, because reader--
writers like you
and I have grown
up reading a certain
kind of text.
And yes, there was the Amy
Tan book that came along.
And then prior to Amy Tan,
there was Maxine Hong
Kingston and, you know--
>> Celeste Ng: Betty--
>> Rumaan Alam: Right.
And there is a lineage
there, but I was reading,
and I'm sure you were reading
the classics that everyone read,
you know, like there
was this like--
the common literature
is what I was reading.
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah, my
mom was very into classics
and very into like Newbery--
>> Rumaan Alam: A very
Asian mom of course.
>> Celeste Ng: -- very into
Newbery winners, so she would--
every time the Newbery
winner came out--
>> Rumaan Alam: She's
read this one,
it's the best one, Celeste, yes.
>> Celeste Ng: -- everybody
[inaudible] this thing
on it right there.
But so it's true.
I mean, I realized that I
grew up with this very sort
of white perception of the
world, which is, you know,
I was reading things like
"The Boxcar Children",
"Little Women", and "The
Five Little Peppers",
and Frances Hodgson Burnett,
you know, "A Little Princess".
Very British, my mom grew up in
Hong Kong and so was educated
in the British school system and
so read a lot of British books
which she then remembered
and wanted to give to me.
And so that's--
>> Rumaan Alam: Did
you read Enid Blyton.
>> Celeste Ng: I did
read Enid Blyton.
>> Rumaan Alam: My parents
also grew up in sort of like--
The British really,
they fucked everything
up in the whole planet.
But, you know, like
there is like a tradition
of anglophone children's
literature inside all
of these other world literatures
now because of the colonial--
>> Celeste Ng: And it spreads
because you read what--
you know, you read that and then
you kind of grow up thinking
about that and you think that's
sort of the empathy you have.
And I think about--
there's this great essay
about the White Cliffs of Dover
in which, you know, they were--
it talks about sort of the--
wanting to sort of fight
against that received image
of like how the world
is supposed to be.
And so it was sort of a tricky
territory for me to want to,
you know, like-- so I'm
writing about a white family.
And people have pointed out, you
know, a lot of the characters
of color are moved to the sides.
One of the main characters
of color is this
Chinese-American baby who's
getting adopted by
a white family
and her Chinese-American
mother who wants her back.
And they're two of the only
characters who aren't at the--
they're not centered
in the narrative,
but they're at the
center of the plot.
And I did that deliberately
actually because I wanted to--
people keep asking, well,
why didn't you ever let the,
you know, the birth mother, why
doesn't she got a lot of point
of view, only a little
at the end?
>> Rumaan Alam: You know,
what you're supposed to say
when people say that is,
why don't you write a book?
[Laughter]
>> Celeste Ng: Well,
and she can--
>> Rumaan Alam: But
please finish it.
>> Celeste Ng: I mean-- But
my thought was, the thing is,
I think it's really easy
when you read a book
and you see characters who are
not like you just say, well,
that's about them, right?
I'm over here and
they're over there
and there are these very
clear differences between us.
It's a lot harder when
you see yourself in some
of the characters to sort
of distance yourself.
So, you know, the book is
not just for people who live
in the suburbs with wealthy
people, white people.
But if you feel a kinship to
any of those things, you go, oh,
this suburb reminds me a
little bit of my hometown,
even if it's different
in these ways.
And then suddenly, you're
in this space where you have
to identify with these
characters and you have
to ask yourself questions,
would I act like that?
Do I act like that?
>> Rumaan Alam: Yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: You know,
how am I different?
Where do I stand?
I mean, that I think is the
real purpose of any art really,
is to sort of ask you to figure
out where you stand in relation
to the world and
ask you to figure
out what your values are
compared to the values
of the characters in the book.
>> Rumaan Alam: It is
a very clear choice,
to my thinking anyway, in
"Little Fires Everywhere"
that the one character who is
nominally closest to Celeste Ng,
the human being, the Chinese
woman who is a mother,
is very much to the
side in the pot.
And that sort of-- To me, that
is a very rich window into,
you know, who you
are as a person
and what it must have been.
It feels like an
autobiographical tell even
though I know that you're
not like the woman--
this character in the text is
sort of a lower class person--
a working class person who is
really going through this sort
of dire circumstance that
I know you did not go
through personally.
But it feels very much informed
by how you probably saw yourself
in the context of
Shaker Heights, Ohio.
>> Celeste Ng: And it's
interesting too that you--
and you asked the
question earlier about sort
of what are the themes
of the book.
When I started writing
the second book,
I was really nervous
because I was thinking
like the first book I
wanted to write about sort
of Asian-American
issues and touch on race,
and I realized I was doing it
sort of from the inside-out.
The first novel has
to do with the family.
Most of the action takes
place within the house.
It's a multiracial family
where the father is
a Chinese-American,
the mother is a white American,
and then they have
three mixed-race kids.
So it's-- I intentionally
set it up as sort
of a claustrophobic sort of
thing because I wanted the story
to be inside, so to speak.
And with the second book,
I said, I want to write
about these same issues but
I want to write about it
from the outside-in and so,
to instead put the focus
with the white characters
essentially to then be looking
at these questions of race
and privilege and all of that.
For me, I mean, they--
I see them as books that are
tackling similar issues but just
on opposite directions.
>> Rumaan Alam: Do you feel
like you're allowed to write
about anything you want?
Or do you feel like a response--
Do you feel a responsibility
to address these subjects?
And it's hard-- This
is a tough question.
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah,
this is a big question.
I don't know the
answer honestly.
I mean, I think am I allowed
to write about anything?
Yes, I think.
>> Rumaan Alam: I mean,
obviously Penguin is going
to pay you for--
Everybody raised their hand
when they said they've
read the book, so.
>> Celeste Ng: Well, I think--
I mean, I think the question
of permission is a big one,
because this is a discussion
that's going on now.
There's a movement within
the literary community
that I think has a lot of valid
points in which people want
to talk about, you know, sort
of writing their own stories.
And that story-- We
should be getting stories
that are told by
their own voices.
And I think there's
something to that.
I mean, you are allowed to
write anything that you want.
Your job is also to imagine your
way into people who are not you.
And so, there's-- again,
there's sort of a tension
between those two things.
For me personally, I
write about the things
that I think about the most.
And so that tends to be parents
and children and this question
of legacy and history and
background, what gets said,
what gets passed down from
generation to generation,
and whether you can actually
be different from your parents.
I'm reaching the age in my
life now where I'm realizing
that I'm turning into both of
my parents and not in the ways
that I expected either in like
completely different ways.
And I'm also-- Because I'm still
a daughter and I am a mother,
I am also trying to figure out,
what am I passing onto my kid?
What do I want you to have
that I had and I value
and I think would
be good for you?
And what are the things that
I don't want to pass onto you?
I know you're also a
parent of small children
and these are the questions that
I think about a lot at night.
And that's what comes
into the book.
>> Rumaan Alam: Yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: So for me,
those questions are always tied
up in questions of
race and gender
because I'm an Asian-American
woman.
And that's the experience
that I've had.
And so, in terms of what
I feel allowed to write,
I could write about anything.
But what I think I'm
going to be good at,
what I think I have something
that I want to figure out,
because for me writing
is always from a place
of not understanding towards
understanding a little better.
And those are the questions
that I'm trying to understand.
And that's why I
keep coming back.
>> Rumaan Alam: I mean, these
are fertile territories.
It's not like you're saying,
I can only ever write novels
about one episode
of Seinfeld, like--
>> Celeste Ng: Exactly.
>> Rumaan Alam: And that's
all I've got to commit
to for the rest of my career.
>> Celeste Ng: Its-- Yeah.
I mean--
>> Rumaan Alam: You're
talking to me it has--
>> Celeste Ng: When
we say we're writing
about only parenting and, you
know, race in the suburbs,
that's a pretty big
thing to write, you know?
>> Rumaan Alam: You mentioned
own voices and this brings
up an interesting question,
or interesting to me anyway.
But do you think there is
the same moral sensitivity
when you are writing across the
difference of race through--
towards whiteness as there
would be if you were writing
about being Latina or
writing about being black?
>> Celeste Ng: That's such
an interesting question.
So this movement, Own Voices, is
sort of the idea that primarily,
stories about sort
of marginalized group
should be written
by people within those groups.
Somebody in the signing line
came to me at the very, very end
and said, I have this
burning question about
"Little Fires Everywhere".
And the question is, I
think, probably the one
that I have been asked the
most often about the book,
which is about the ethnicity of
Mia and Pearl, who are a mother
and daughter in this story
who come in from out of town.
And they said, you know,
basically like what
is their ethnicity?
Are they white or are
they people of color?
What are they?
And the truth is, since you're
all here, I'm just going
to confess to all of you.
The truth is that when I
started writing the book,
I thought I wanted them
to be people of color.
And I thought, well, I don't
want to make them Asian
because I knew there was going--
the book was going to center
around this trans-racial
adoption of an Asian baby.
And it seemed like that
would make the loyalties too
clear-cut, right?
Like well, people
would say, well,
of course the Asian
woman is going to side
with the Asian mother
keeping the Asian baby.
But I didn't feel like I knew
enough to write the experience
of a black woman
or a Latina woman.
>> Rumaan Alam: Right.
>> Celeste Ng: I
felt like I wasn't--
Honestly, I wasn't
going to do enough--
a good enough job
and I didn't feel
like that was my story to tell.
And so I wrote the two
characters thinking about them
as a white mother
and a white daughter.
And I love that the
TV adaptation is going
to star Kerry Washington as Mia.
>> Rumaan Alam: Gosh, no.
>> Celeste Ng: So she's going
to be starring as a black woman.
And I love that it's going
to raise these questions,
because I don't know
the answer to that.
>> Rumaan Alam: Well,
thanks for nothing, Celeste.
>> Celeste Ng: I know.
This is a long way--
>> Rumaan Alam: You're
supposed to know the answer.
>> Celeste Ng: This was a long
way of dodging the question.
I think the answer comes under
maybe the best writing advice
that I've ever gotten which
is that you can do anything
that you want to as long as
you can get away with it.
>> Rumaan Alam: Yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: And I think
how-- so how do you--
the question then is, how do you
know if you got away with it?
>> Rumaan Alam: How do you know?
>> Celeste Ng: And I think it's
if you'd asked people who have
that experience and they say,
yeah, you got it or you didn't,
you listen to them, right?
Obviously, there is no
one black experience just
like there's no one
Asian experience,
there's no one anything
experience.
But I think that part of
your job is to write--
in writing any characters,
you write as best
as you can, as truly as you can.
And if people tell you, I didn't
believe that, it didn't match
up with my experience, then you
have to take that seriously.
>> Rumaan Alam: Yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: It's a
sort of giant like feeling
around in the dark process
that I think we do as writers.
But with the added benefit
of, you know, race being a lot
of things that we trip
over in this darker room.
Yeah.
>> Rumaan Alam: And you just
don't know until it's done,
which is the challenge.
We have about 15 minutes left.
And I know a lot of you are
going to have questions.
So go ahead and starting
thinking
of really good questions
that are not comments
and that are not requests for
Celeste to read your new book.
And I'm going to ask to
you one more question
because you mentioned Amy Tan
and you mentioned the idea
that there can be
one person of color,
one sort of representative
from a group
in the imagination at a time.
And I have noticed and I'm
sure you have noticed a sort
of Celeste Ng effect in
the fiction marketplace
and you laugh but I know that
you know what I'm talking about
and I know that this summer
in particular has been a
really robust time for debut
of literary novels by women
of Asian descent generally,
not Chinese specifically.
There's sort of like a slew
of different kinds of books,
Crystal Hana Kim's
book, Lucy Tan--
>> Celeste Ng: Somebody
earlier described it
as like we're having a Korean
women moment, and I was like,
I hope they have
more than one moment.
But I know what you mean.
>> Rumaan Alam: And I
want to hear your-- like--
I'm not making this up.
Like this is something that
you've observed yourself
and I'd love to hear you talk
about what that means to you.
I mean, that's like an-- I
think that's really testament
to something really
exciting, and I'd love
to hear what you thing--
>> Celeste Ng: I mean, I have
complicated feelings about that.
So, we'll try not to make
this into a therapy session.
I-- On the one hand,
I am thrilled to--
that there are more young
Asian-American women writing,
that there are more
Asian voices,
that there are more just
frankly more diverse voices.
I was really happy
to see Tommy Orange,
who's a native writer whose book
hit the New York Times list.
You know, I think there
are really exciting writers
that are writing stories
that traditionally, I think,
have been held up by
publishers like, we don't know
if people will buy that.
And I feel like now, we're
seeing that people will buy that
and read it, and
these are good books.
So if I've had anything to do
with that, I'm really happy.
Ages ago, somebody
said to me that being
in the writing world is like
a lot of people fighting
over one very, very small piece
of cake and then you realize
at a certain point that actually
there is not even any cake,
[laughter] which is
sort of sadly true.
But my thought about that is
that then our job has to be
to make more cake for other
people, that if, you know,
if you're saying that, you
know, there's only so many seats
at the table, then I feel
like when you get a seat,
your job is to try and
pull out more chairs.
And I honestly do believe that.
>> Rumaan Alam: And I do think
of you as a writer who has--
you know, I think Celeste
is being pretty humble here.
But I think of you as someone
who has very actively supported
the careers of younger writers,
not just writers of Asian
descent or writers who happen
to be Asian women like
you, that you are very--
you see the responsibility
that you have as a writer
who has enjoyed some
degree of success,
and you seem very invested
in passing that on.
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah, and I am.
I mean, this is where
I would feel that I'm
like a Marvel superhero dork.
But there's this-- If you've
ever seen the Spiderman movie,
this is the line that you
keep repeating over and over
with it-- like with-- you know,
with great power comes
great responsibility.
And I feel like that,
that if I have a platform,
that I want to use it to try
and share with other people
and help other people
tell their voices.
And this brings me to my--
back to my mixed feelings,
which is that I fight really
hard against the idea that,
you know, I am any kind of
chosen one or that I'm going
to be like the next Amy Tan,
because I think that's a
really harmful way of thinking.
I mean, I think the truth is
that I'm not going to speak
for everybody just
as Amy doesn't speak
for-- nobody speaks for--
>> Rumaan Alam: There's
no monolithic experience
of anything.
>> Celeste Ng: That's
exactly it.
And so I think-- And
Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie,
who's an amazing writer,
the author of "We
Should All Be Feminists"
and "Americanah" among other
things has a great TED Talk
about this, which I encourage
all of you to go and watch
if you've never seen it.
Just Google, TED Talk, Danger of
a Single Story, where she talks
about how this is a really
dangerous way of thinking.
Because, first, that
one story is not going
to represent everybody, so you
need more voices to be heard.
And second, it puts a
huge amount of pressure
on those particular stories
to talk for everyone.
>> Rumaan Alam: Yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: I'm thinking--
We were talking about this
being this sort of August
of Asian-Americans with "Crazy
Rich Asians" and all this.
And there have been bunch of
articles questioning whether,
you know, is "Crazy Rich
Asians" Asian enough,
because it only shows this one
segment of Asian population?
And my thought is, right,
it's the crazy rich--
>> Rumaan Alam: Right.
[Laughter]
>> Celeste Ng: -- section.
Like Asia is really big.
It involves a lot of
different people who have a lot
of different experiences.
And even-- You can't even say
that, you know, like this is all
of Singapore, because
there's a lot
of different groups
in Singapore.
There's a lot of
different everything.
And to say, you know, that like
if you say there's only going
to be this one movie and it's
got to represent everybody,
you're almost dooming
that from the beginning.
And I think the only
way to solve
that is to have more voices.
We need more Asian women,
we need more Asian men.
We need more, you know,
black men and black women
and we need more gay stories
and we need more like--
we need more everything
basically.
So that's sort of the
responsibility that I feel
in trying to sort of boost
other people's voices,
is just to make there be more.
>> Rumaan Alam: That's
a great answer.
Does anybody have any questions?
I can't believe--
>> Celeste Ng: I know
there's no questions.
>> Rumaan Alam: -- there aren't
a million people lined up.
Like--
>> Celeste Ng: We
can keep talking.
>> Rumaan Alam: We
We have a lot of
fronts to cover--
>> Celeste Ng: I will
also take goofy questions.
If you want to know what
my favorite candy is,
I'm here to talk about candy.
Yes?
>> Ohio in here, and I wanted to
know how you went about writing
about the place that
you grew up.
Did you just do it from memory?
Did you go back to Shaker
Heights and explore?
And then how much do you
feel like you have to stick
to the facts and how much
can you make it also a place
of imagination?
>> Celeste Ng: Well, so, when
I wrote about Shaker Heights,
I was terrified basically.
Because when you're
writing about your hometown
or you're writing about
any real place, there--
I think you have an obligation
to try and portray that place
as accurately as you can,
and also because other
people might show up and say,
that's not where the school is.
That's not-- [Laughter] And if
any of you know Shaker Heights
and I know there are some of you
out there because you've come
up to tell me that you're
from Shaker Heights,
I have definitely gotten
emails about various things
that I got wrong about
Shaker Heights, because--
>> Rumaan Alam: Don't
do-- Don't email that.
Going forward, just
don't email that, yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: To be
fair, one was my mom
where the first thing
she said after she--
[laughter] after she read the
first, I think, page-and-a-half,
she said, isn't it
South Woodland like Road
and not South Woodland
Boulevard?
And I said, mom, that's the
first thing you noticed?
So actually, it's your question.
I tried to be as
accurate as I could.
I had a map of Shaker Heights.
I did go back to Shaker.
I pulled out my yearbooks which
was an interesting experience
to revisit my high school life.
The Shaker Heights Public
Library was an amazing resource
and I feel like this is where
I should give a shout-out
to libraries and librarians.
They have actually a
room of local history.
And so when I went in and I
told the wonderful local history
librarian, Meghan Hayes, what
I was looking for, I said,
I'm interested in this period,
she pulled out school
newspapers from that era.
You know, I found an
editorial that I had written
in junior year of high school
for the guest editorial.
But I could find
out so many things
about like what restaurants were
we going to, how much did a cup
of coffee cost, because
they were telling you
where you'd get the best value
for your coffee,
all these things.
So, I tried to make the
facts of Shaker Heights
as accurate as possible.
And then where I tried to
allow myself sort of that space
of imagination that you talk
about was with the characters,
to think about what
sort of characters
who don't exist might
do in this real place.
Thank you.
I guess you should go up here.
>> Hi. So, I identify
as mixed Asian-American
and I've been having a lot of
conversations recently with my,
I guess, full-race
Asian-American friends and a lot
of them have never really
thought about what it's
like to be mixed and to be half.
And I'm really curious
about how you decided
to make the characters in
your first book biracial
because it's not
something we see a lot,
so I'm really interested to
see what you're inspired by.
>> Celeste Ng: Great.
Yeah, I think this is a
conversation that's happening
more and more for
really good reasons
because there are more
multiracial kids out there.
It's something that I
thought about a lot because--
first, because I'm the mom
of a biracial kid, I have a--
my husband is white so
we have a mixed kid.
And I think of a lot about of
what his experience is going
to be like.
We happened to live on a
street where four houses
in a row have mixed-race
families.
So, my son thinks that this is
totally normal and all the kids
on the street kind
of look like him.
And I love that he's able
to have that experience.
For me, it was also a way
for me to try and write
about Chinese-American identity
in a way that felt right to me,
because I've always felt sort
of like a fake Asian in a way.
Both of my parents
came from Hong Kong
but I was born here
in the States.
I've lived my whole life here.
I don't speak Cantonese.
I feel in a lot of ways like I
don't know all the Asian things,
the Chinese things that
I'm supposed to know.
And so this was a way
for me to sort of write
about the difficulties of
feeling like you have parts
of your identity in
two different places.
And it may be that I didn't
get it right, but I'm hoping
that there will be
more stories out there
so that other people
can tell those stories.
Thank you.
We'll go here and I'll try and
be faster so I can get finished.
Yes?
>> So thank you.
So I've read both authors'
books and I can't help but note
that there are real
similarities, both of them talk
about white privilege with
very privileged white suburban
families, transracial adoption
is a theme in both books.
So I'm wondering, for
both of you, what you see
as similarities and differences
in the way you approached
your stories
and also why now do you
think that, you know,
both your stories are emerging
and that there is an audience
who's very interested,
at least I am, in reading
these stories and feeling
like they have a
lot to offer us?
>> Rumaan Alam: I was
shocked when I got your book.
I-- I'm trying to remember
when I would have got--
I think I must have been--
>> Celeste Ng: If you
were finishing the draft
of "That Kind of
Mother"-- So Rumaan's book,
"That Kind of Mother",
also deals with a
transracial adoption.
>> Rumaan Alam: And
so I got your book
and I didn't know anything
about it, and I read it
and I was like, wow,
this is terrible.
A much more successful
novelist has written
on exactly the same subject.
[Laughter] But actually,
I think--
I actually found it like so
enticing and like fascinating
that we had both
ended up on, you know,
the tension between being
an artist and being a mother
on the question of adoption.
Like it's just-- It was
like a funny coincidence.
>> Celeste Ng: And I then came
up with two very
different books, right?
So you should also
read my last book.
>> Rumaan Alam: Two
very different books,
a successful one and
a less successful one.
>> Celeste Ng: But to more
seriously answer your question
though, I think that I
don't know why this is sort
of a topic that's coming
up but I'm glad that it is.
And one of the reasons might
be that I think that especially
over the past, let's
say, two years,
we're talking a lot more
openly about issues of race,
which I think is difficult
but I think is also a
really important thing,
because we have race problems
in America and it's complicated.
And it comes-- you know,
it manifests itself
in a lot of different ways.
And I think it's just becoming
part of the conversation.
I mean, I started writing this
book many years before the 2016
election, race issues didn't--
were not invented
by that election.
They'd been there all the time.
I think it's just
now, they're sort
of floating up to the surface.
>> Rumaan Alam: And then
as the previous woman
who asked the question
before, the population
in this country is changing
and so the question only becomes
more salient as time passes.
And as-- You know, in
Celeste's first book,
the couple at the heart of the
book, this interracial couple,
when they are married,
their marriage is not even legal
throughout the United States
because it predates
Loving versus Virginia.
So, we have come a
long way as a society
and we are going
still further I think.
>> Celeste Ng: Yeah.
I think we're continuing
in that direction,
and so that's the
population that we are.
>> Thank you.
>> So I actually-- I went to
college outside of Cleveland
so I'm familiar with
Shaker Heights.
So it was--
>> Celeste Ng: Did
you go to Oberlin?
>> No, I didn't.
I went to Kent State, but
I have friends at JCU--
>> Celeste Ng: This is like
the code people use sometimes.
>> So it was really cool to read
your book and kind of, you know,
it's always neat to
have that experience
of reading someone's version
of a place that you've been
and experienced somewhat
intimately.
But I think that,
you know, your--
the way that you described
Shaker is, you know,
with all the detail that you
used and everything else,
it's more than a plot or
rather more than a setting.
It almost feels like another
character in the book and--
but at the same time,
your plot is so finely
and intricately woven together
that you have all of these,
you know, kind of breadcrumbs
that you would leave throughout
the novel and then they sort
of culminate together.
And so I was just
interested to find
out like what's your process
like when you're writing a book
that you have so many, you know,
really salient kind of parts?
Like where do you begin?
Do you begin with your place
or what you want your
characters to be like?
Or, you know, how do you
build that culminating moment?
>> Celeste Ng: This is a big
question for writers, right,
which is sort of like,
how did you do that?
My-- And I wish I knew
because I am know trying
to write a third book and
I am trying desperately
to remember how I did
it the first two times.
For "Little Fires Everywhere",
it's-- it makes sense that you,
you know, start it off
thinking about Shaker Heights
because that was sort of where
the story started for me also.
For me, it was sort of like
a character and I wanted--
I knew I wanted to
write about this place.
And so for me, it really
started with that place
and I imagined sort of
what a prototypical family
in that place might look like.
And that's sort of how I
came up with the Richardsons,
if you imagine the most
quintessential Shaker family--
Shaker Heights family,
I should say,
that they had-- that
might be them.
And I sort of tried to
imagine sort of what kind
of trouble I could
stir up for them,
because that's what writers do.
So we're mean to our
characters, we make trouble.
And this other family from out
of town came in, who were going
to be really, you know,
at odds with them.
And so, for me, that's sort of--
once I have those
characters together,
it's almost like you put them--
you've got your little figurines
in and you just let them
fight it out with each other.
So for me, a lot of the process
is just sort of imagining what--
you know, how they would poke
at each other, how they would,
you know, irritate each other,
how they would find
connections for each other.
For me, there's a lot of
going down blind alleys
in trying to figure out--
>> Rumaan Alam: I was going to
ask you, do you know in advance
or are you surprised by
where the narrative moves?
>> Celeste Ng: I know the
general arc of it usually.
I usually can't get
going until I have sort
of a destination in mind.
It's like planning a road trip.
I know where I'm going and
I have an idea I'm going
to stop here and here.
But I don't always take
the route that I expect,
so there's space for questions
but I knew for example
from the beginning
that it was going
to end with this house fire.
This doesn't give anything away,
it happens on the first page.
[Laughter] But similarly--
>> Rumaan Alam: It
happens in the title--
>> Celeste Ng: It
happens in the title.
So I knew that.
How exactly it was gong
to shake out was sort
of the discovery process for me.
I'm seeing this--
>> Rumaan Alam: We're supposed
to wrap it up but I feel
like we're the last
event in the room,
so I feel like you could answer
one more question, right?
>> Celeste Ng: OK, I think I
can answer one more question.
So--
>> Hi.
>> Celeste Ng: Hi.
>> So, when I was younger,
I read that Kurt Vonnegut.
The reason I thought I liked
him was because he was able
to marry humor to the
very serious, the dark.
As I got older, I understood
it was his lack of judgment
on the characters that he wrote.
He as a person could judge
as we see in his nonfiction,
he felt a little freer in
nonfiction to be judgmental.
What is the author's
responsibility
to their characters as far
as judgment is concerned?
>> Celeste Ng: Oh, that is a
really interesting question.
Why--
>> Rumaan Alam: You caused them
trouble, you just said you liked
to cause-- you cause
them trouble but--
>> Celeste Ng: You do.
Well, trouble is what makes
stories interesting, right?
If you-- You know, if someone
says, how was your day,
and you were like, my day was
great, that's kind of the end.
>> Rumaan Alam: It's
a short story, yeah.
>> Celeste Ng: It's
a very short story.
But the question of sort of what
about judging your characters,
I think, is really great
one, because I actually feel
that if the author comes to
their characters with contempt,
it shows in the story.
And I think you have
to, as an author,
love your characters
even if you don't agree
with what they're doing.
So, in both of my novels, I've
got characters who, I think,
make some pretty bad choices,
or choices that I would
not make, let's say.
>> Rumaan Alam: Sort
of an understatement.
>> Celeste Ng: And I actually
think every single character
makes some choices
that are maybe poorly--
>> Rumaan Alam: Questionable.
>> -- judged.
Questionable is a
nice way to put it.
And so, I feel like, you
know, I've got my own opinions
but my job as the
author is not--
is to not make heroes
and villains.
My son is seven and he's at
this age where they're really
into who the good guys
and the bad guys are.
And what I try to get through to
him is that bad guys don't think
that they're bad guys.
The bad guys usually think
that they are the good guys.
And so, my job, I think, is
rather than to get the reader
to condemn all the people that I
hate and to love all the people
that I love, rather to present
them with these characters
so that at the end,
hopefully they say, well,
I really didn't like
that person.
But I kind of understand
why she did what she did.
That's sort of usually
my goal as a writer,
is to make you see the
complexity of what a person is,
even if you still think
that you would never want
to have a beer with
Mrs. Richardson.
I don't think she's
not really a beer--
>> Rumaan Alam: She's
not a beer-drinker,
she's like a chardonnay-drinker
but--
>> Celeste Ng: So you never
have a chardonnay with her.
But I think that's sort
of the best answer I have
for the question, is
that, you know, you're--
if you've condemned
your characters
or if you are wholeheartedly
sort of waving the flag for one
of your characters, then I think
actually you haven't looked
at the characters close enough.
I think that your job
as the writer is really
to show your characters
as humans,
which means that they're
going to be flawed.
And I think that that
often is sort of,
for novels that don't work
for me, that's often the case
where the author hasn't
looked closely enough.
>> Rumaan Alam: Well,
I think that everyone
in the room will
agree that you--
that mission accomplished
on that.
So, it was such a
pleasure to hear from you
about your two wonderful books.
And thank you so much.
This was great.
>> Celeste Ng: Thank you.
[Applause]